Taylor Swift is giving back to fans and
spending time with friends following her
breakup from Tom Hiddleston 26 year old
facetimed is 18 year old named Megan
who's battling a congenital heart defect
Megan tweeted about the special
experience on Thursday sharing these
photos of her chatting with Taylor and a
thank you note she pinned to the singer
it faded a really good day the newly
single star also put a call in to
another struggling fan Maddy and donated
five thousand dollars to the family of a
girl who died in the car accident over
Labor Day weekend Taylor's good deeds
come after she pledged to donate 1
million dollars to help victims of the
Louisiana floods last month I'm spare no
expense and her next stop Fashion Week
Gigi Hadid and tommy hilfiger revealed
in his news during a press conference
for Gigi's Tommy Hilfiger collection on
Friday just ahead of their runway show
one of one of the things that we really
had to organize was getting the right
seat for in Gigi's friend Taylor Swift
so oh that is the best kind of
friendship you can have